tonight on Brian Ross investigates one
time wrong place as the president flies
off to Tulsa for his first post pandemic
campaign rally historians wonder why he
chose the site of the worst race
massacre in American history hundreds of
black citizens killed a prosperous
community destroyed by mobs of white
vigilantes as the police stood by all
that President Trump can say is I resign
I realized that I am a racist I am over
my head
the Tulsa newspaper says of the
president we can't see any way that his
visit will be good for the city plus the
election and the pandemic we're joined
by a law professor who warns of more
chaos at the polls this November it's
just harder when you get there it's
harder to work out and dr. William
Schaffner who reminds us that pandemic
has hardly gone away and this week's
winners and losers in the media has
chosen by media watch the showdown
between a Trump campaign lawyer CNN
media analyst Brian stone let me finish
are you you're just gonna interrupt me
this whole time er can we actually have
a reasonable dialog from the law and
crime Network this is Brian Ross in this
thank you for joining us and welcome to
our viewers on Facebook live and You
Tube live i'm brian ross joined today by
my colleague at the law and crime
Network Rhonda Schwartz and Rhonda we
begin with the president's planned trip
at the end of this week to Tulsa
Oklahoma for a campaign rally in the
middle of a pandemic as the country
suffers a crisis of racial injustice
that's right Brian there was strong
reaction to the news that the president
would hold his rally the Tulsa World
newspaper flatly said this is the wrong
time and Tulsa is the wrong place for
the Trump rally all it will do is
concentrate the world's attention on a
city that 99 years ago was the site of a
bloody race Massacre that's right Rhonda
it was 1921 and what police then called
a Negro uprising but was in fact the
worst racial massacre in American
history
hundreds of innocent black citizens
killed and a thriving black community
was destroyed a place that it come to be
called the black Wall Street
joined now by dr. Carol Anderson a
professor of african-american studies at
Emory University and historian and
journalist James Hirsch thank you both
for being here let me start by saying
this stain on American history is still
not widely taught in American high
schools that's true it's for many years
in the state of Oklahoma even the riot
was never discussed not taught in
schools not mentioned in newspapers and
it was really a conspiracy of silence
for quite a few decades and only really
in the last 20 years or so has there
been an effort in Oklahomans self to
understand what happened in 1921 but
beyond Oklahoma you're correct it is not
widely known what happened in 1921 and
the very painful legacy as well and
surrenders and as you look at this has
any race Massacre ever been more severe
than what happened in Tulsa in 1921
we've come close which is so unfortunate
we have had the slaughter in Colfax
Louisiana in 1873 we've had the
destruction of the black community in
Wilmington North Carolina in 1898 we had
Rosewood we had Ocoee Florida we have
had the the pogrom the the ethnic
cleansing that happened in Forsyth
County Georgia so we've seen so much of
this what Tulsa stands out in so many
ways because it had the black Wall
Street because of the depth of the
violence because of the use of the
airplane and bombing the black community
the absolute destruction in the and the
inability and refusal to even
acknowledge that destruction and you
know James talked about the complicity
of silence but you also have the
complicity of the political and legal
system that allowed that atrocity that
massacre to happen um without recompense
without justice
and what actually triggered it was it
resentment but the immediate trigger was
the arrest of a young african-american
who was charged with assaulting a white
woman and that led to an incendiary
article in a local newspaper and it
raised you know the worst taboo of
American life at that time a black man
allegedly attacking a white woman
ultimately those charges were dropped
they were false
but once that article appeared in the
paper there was all kinds of concerns
that the accused was going to be lynched
that in turn led to a group of black men
to come to the courthouse to protect the
accused they were met by a group of
white men that trigger of
melee and there were casualties on both
sides but then the real riot or I
referred to really as the invasion
occurred early the following morning
when several thousand white men invaded
the black section of Tulsa with guns
with torches with kerosene and
systematically destroyed all the
institutions that perpetuated black life
in Tulsa the churches hospitals schools
businesses etc
and professor Anderson this was known as
the black Wall Street hugely successful
black community you've talked about the
issue of resentment yes yes I mean this
is vintage white rage that I have
discussed where you have
african-americans advancing you have
african-americans achieving their civil
rights Julian what they're supposed to
do and instead of finding the embrace of
American democracy
what they find is the simmering seething
resentment looking for any excuse
whatsoever to to destroy that
advancement and so the the allegation by
Sarah page that dick Rowland had had had
had done something to her in that
elevator which of course was not true it
was more than enough the the temerity
that african-americans had to be afraid
that dick was going to get lynched given
that there had been lynchings repeated
lynchings and in 1921 I believe there
did almost 60 lynchings something back
fifty nine or so in that year alone so
their fears were not on unjust their
fears were were logical but the fact
that they were wealthy the fact that
they were educated the fact that they
worked hard the fact that they were
church-going god-fearing the fact that
they had a level of success they had
tasted the American Dream that fueled
incredible resentment why would you
bother hospitals why would you bomb
churches why would you burn them up
resentment and Frankie is there ninety
nine years later yep absolutely
I was there and and the purpose was not
only to punish those aspiring black
families in Tulsa but it was to send a
message across Oklahoma and across the
country that this is what happens when
black people tried to assert their
rights there were photographs taken
cards created because the the white mob
wanted to send that that message of fear
of terrorism that if you try to advance
these are the consequences and 99 years
later there have been calls for
reparations but has anything been done
to make amends for what happened there
professor Anderson you know there was
the Commission that was founded toward
the in some time in the 1990s and it had
came to the recommendation that there
should be some kind of reparations you
had Charles Ogletree and gay MacDougall
taking the case all the way up to the
courts for the OAS the Organization of
American States that human rights court
and you have a State Department arguing
that no they shouldn't get reparations
so really no no no conjecture shoot what
do you look at ninety nine years later
yeah it's a really important point
because there is a debate in America
about reparations for the descendants of
slaves and whether that users is not
appropriate when may Tulsa different
back when this Commission was created in
the end of the 1990s is that we were not
talking about the descendants of the
victims of the Tulsa Race Riot we're
talking with the actual victims there
were a hundred and eighteen survivors
still with us who were direct who had
been direct victims of that assault and
the city and the state were responsible
so there was a lot of optimism 20 years
ago that those victims would receive
reparations but unfortunately neither
the city nor the state would take
responsibility for what happened in 1921
and they refused to make those payments
to those actual victims
and now professor Anderson the president
is going there this Saturday to give his
first sort of post pandemic campaign
rally the Tulsa World paper says it's
the wrong time in the wrong place what
do you say about his choice as a
location for this rally I would say
first it's not post pandemic we're still
in it and the fact that he would choose
also of all places it reminds me of
Ronald Reagan choosing Neshoba County
Mississippi where the civil rights
workers James Chaney Andrew Goodman and
Mickey Schwerner were killed which led
to the Civil Rights Act of 64 it was to
send a signal and so Trump go into Tulsa
of all of the places Tulsa is not in
Oklahoma is not in play in this
presidential campaign so the fact that
he's kicking off in Tulsa is to send a
signal one about black folks needing to
get back in their place two about the
approval of state sanctioned violence
and terrorism and and three that black
people do not have any rights that white
folks are bound to respect
that is what Tulsa is for a president
who launched his political career on
birtherism and Mexicans are rapists and
criminals it is steeped in white
supremacy as is the destruction of black
Wall Street and James Hearst is a former
journalist at the New York Times The
Wall Street Journal a respected
historian how is this going to go down
you think among the residents of Tulsa
and is there anything he could say that
would be pertinent or would be somehow
important I cannot imagine what Trump
could say that would be pertinent
because his own track record of divisive
rhetoric is so deeply established that I
don't think he could go down there and
be something that he's suddenly not
however I actually think Trump going to
Tulsa
is a good thing because now it allows
the country to learn the lessons of that
city and I think with what the lessons
of the Tulsa riot are in large part is
that you even when it came to helping
the victims of the riot
in 1921 or 2000 or now we betrayed those
those victims and the lesson is that
protests Commission's righteous
indignation all of those by their own
are not enough to bring about social
justice and racial equality what we need
that is leadership and moral courage in
that sense I think Trump going to Tulsa
is oddly fitting as a reminder of where
our country has been and how far we need
to go
professor Anderson finally let me ask
you is there anything you'd want to hear
from the President of the United States
as he speaks in Tulsa the scene of this
horrible stay in American history Oh
President Trump can say is I resign I
realize that I am a racist I am over my
head I have botched the coronavirus I I
have watched the economy
I am unqualified and I'm gone
and I'm turning myself over to
authorities to be investigated for all
of my crimes
that might work and that's it well
professor Carol Anderson at Emory thank
you so much for joining us in James
Hirsch appreciate both of you being here
we'll be watching what happens this
Saturday and let's hear back from you
after the event thank you important
medical news in the fight against the
covert 19 disease we'll be joined by dr.
William Schaffner from Vanderbilt
University you're watching the law on
crime trial Network
back now Rhonda Schwartz this country
continues to be in the middle of a
pandemic yet the president United States
is heading to Tulsa with a campaign
rally where people may not be wearing
their masks they'll be congregating
that's right and the Tulsa Health
Director said today an indoor rally for
20,000 people is a perfect storm in a
state where the coronavirus cases are
increasing he said it hurts my heart to
think of people being exposed to this
illness let's get more on this from dr.
William Schaffner from Vanderbilt
University a real expert of this country
on preventive medicine dr. Shafter what
do you make of this idea have a huge
campaign rally indoors with 20,000
people in the middle of a pandemic
well Brian and Rhonda I'm concerned
about this in fact I'm dismayed by it
because as the city health director said
this is a perfect environment for the
corona virus for kovat it's made to
order a large number of people gathering
from many areas coming together in an
enclosed space close to each other for
prolonged period of time and they'll be
exercising their lungs they'll be
cheering and having a good time and this
is exactly how this respiratory virus
likes to be transmitted we need to
remind ourselves you can be feeling
perfectly well but be infected with the
virus you don't know that and you can
transmit this virus I think that there
will be very few people wearing masks in
that baudet aureum and I'm afraid the
Kovach virus will be attending not
invited but will be there and there will
be some spread and people will take it
back home to their families and to their
communities this is not anything that
anyone in public health or infectious
diseases would have wished for that goes
for the demonstrations that we've seen
the social demonstrations but at the
very least they were outside and many
people were wearing masks but avoiding
large gatherings continues to be very
very important as we open up we need to
go carefully not care carelessly and dr.
Schechter this almost seems to be an
open defiance of the best advice from
you and the people at the CDC and the
president's own health advisors well the
people from the CDC all public health
authorities across the country have been
uniformed we're all in harmony as we go
forward and we need to we need to do
this we need to open up the social the
cultural and the economic aspects of
kovat have been huge but we can do this
if we keep a careful balance opening up
carefully will minimize the impact on
the medical side we don't want to make
people sick I don't think there's a
single person out there who wants to
make other people sick but if we do it
heedlessly then that will surely be a
consequence and as I see institutions
and communities opening up this summer
my own included there's a proportion of
people out there who are simply going
about as though it were yesterday er
instead of tomorrow and we really need
to be careful about this dr. Schaffner a
question for you for Rhonda Schwarz
Rhonda to that point dr. Schaffner we
saw that cases are going down in many
states but in more than 20 states the
number of cases seems to be on the rise
are we already at the start of the
second wave well you could call it a
second wave others are calling it the
continuation of the first wave but
whatever you call it it ought to give us
a big yellow caution light because
clearly we're testing more and finding
more cases but more cases are indeed
occurring because many of us are
opening up heedlessly you know the mass
should be fashioned forward at all times
you walk out of your front door you
should have that mask on watch the
social distancing and avoid large group
gatherings all of those things are going
to be mantras they ought to be part of
our behavior as we're going forward
because we want to minimize the damage
we don't want to see a continuing stream
of patients coming to our emergency
rooms having to be hospitalized and put
in intensive care units goodness knows
nobody wants that
but the coded virus is not going on a
summer holiday it's still with us and
it's moving from major metropolitan
areas out into more rural areas so those
parts of the country less I say more
sparsely settled are now starting to
experience kovin for themselves and
doctors after finally there were some
good medical news today out of Oxford
with the report that a commonly used
generic steroid was very successful in
treating severely ill patients who had
kovat 90s you see me smiling there are
many studies underway around the world
now about therapies how can we treat
people better if they get sick and the
first of this summer's harvest is
starting to come in a steroid an
anti-inflammatory drug that we have been
using for over 40 years actually in
rather small doses used in people who
were intubated or who needed oxygen it
improved their survival and isn't that
good news
it's not perfect not everyone approved
some people still died this doesn't give
us license to go out and create
hullabaloo because the stream of
patients coming in will be constant or
increased just as I've said but once
they're here we now have another
therapeutic agent one that we're
very familiar with that we can use to
alleviate some of the most severe
symptoms and improve survival we'll take
every little bit we can get that's right
as dr. Anthony Fauci said doctor in a
game with very few hits a double off the
wall is not bad dr. William Schaffner
thank you so much again for joining us
today
my pleasure to both of you we'll watch
this covin evolve over the course of the
summer I hope we can keep dampening that
curve all right coming up what all this
means for the November election could
the president postpone the voting you're
watching the law and crime trial Network
continuing now with chaos in Georgia
even before an innocent black man was
shot in the back by police officers and
killed there was chaos at the polls a
primary election where there were long
lines 5-hour weights new voting machines
didn't work not enough poll workers some
polling places were closed
is this an omen for what could happen
across the country this coming November
the Atlanta mayor talked about how bad
it was just a complete meltdown on
yesterday we saw this with early voting
even on Friday I have a neighbor who
stood in line for almost eight hours
someone told me about their neighbor who
was in line until 2:30 a.m. attempting
to vote and it is absolutely ridiculous
coming out of 2016 specifically when
there were so many questions about the
integrity of our election to be here
again in 2020 under these circumstances
really it's unacceptable joining us now
to talk about this is Kimberly Whaley a
former federal prosecutor CBS News legal
analyst a professor of law and the
author of a new book just out today what
you need to know about voting and why
professor Whaley what do we need to know
about voting in light of what happened
in Georgia the chaos there we need to
know that November is going to have some
spots of chaos no matter how hard I
think election officials try to make
everything go smoothly there are lots of
barriers to that and so everyone who's
watching needs to register as quickly as
possible registration is down because of
Kogan places for registering like the
DMV have not been open voter
registration drives haven't been
happening and then of course states are
now have lower tax rates because of
kogut they don't have the kind of money
that is needed to have a really
well-functioning electoral process so we
could see lines we will see potentially
broken machines we will see poll workers
who are not properly trained or or it is
sufficiently trained or not enough
of them by virtue of many of them being
on the older side and so they're more
susceptible to koban this is a moment
where we're just going to have to work
person by person friend by took my
friend to get our votes account and that
means voting by mail and if that doesn't
work
show up the polls with your hand
sanitizer in your masks and just be
ready to wait in line and know that at
the end of the day if you're in line you
cannot be turned away and if you show up
and someone tells you you don't have the
right identification error or not in the
right space you can always ask under
federal law or what's called a
provisional ballot they have to let you
vote and then you might need to do some
follow-up in your particular state to
confirm your identity and have your
provisional ballot counted professor
Bailey can you see under the law
scenario in which President Trump with
his polls way down and perhaps he feels
like he's not going to win whether he
could somehow delay the election
postpone it I don't think the President
himself has that power for better or
worse our system is not a federal system
it's a state-by-state system and even
precinct by precinct but those systems
are managed by elected officials usually
there are secretaries of state in
particular states and that those to the
extent to which they are Republicans and
loyal to mr. Trump they can certainly
make mischief between now and then
closing polling spaces out places making
it harder to prevent ID that was
satisfactory not allowing a more
expanded mail-in voting there are
multiple lawsuits happening right now
across the country mr. Trump has vowed
to veto legislation to bail out the
bankrupt u.s. postal system that is due
to run out of money in September so this
will be sort of a chipping away at the
right to vote where it's just harder to
get to the polls when you get there it's
harder to have your your vote count but
I don't want people to hear this and
stay at home
studies show that number one impediment
to voting is apathy or cynicism and we
are live in a country where so far we've
had free and fair elections and that's a
proof
and voting is the cornerstone of
anything else that you care about in
your life that can be affected by
elected officials climate change the
economy medical costs all of that if we
don't have a functioning electoral
process all of that goes out the window
and really American democracy and the
legitimacy of American elections are
hanging in the balance in November so we
have to hold hands and work against
those forces that are trying to keep us
from the polls the President and some
Republicans have claimed that mail-in
ballots lead to widespread fraud from
your investigation and working on this
book is there evidence of that no there
is no evidence of that first of all
there are five states including the
republican-leaning Utah that exclusively
do elections by mail and there's there
they've been run smoothly there aren't
huge problems a study done between 2000
and 2014 that looked at a billion with a
B ballots found 31 credible examples of
voter fraud that's a drop in the ocean
this is not a serious problem there's
also a federal law that prohibits and
criminalizes as a felony voter fraud so
if you go and you try to trick someone
and vote when you're not allowed to hey
you're not going to change the election
and B you could go to jail for five
years so I just don't think there's an
incentive there and it certainly doesn't
outweigh this massive both deliberate
and by virtue I think incompetence and
lack of funding massive to voter
disenfranchisement when at the end of
the day our entire constitutional
structure hinges on the ability of We
the People to self govern at the ballot
box professor in the last election there
was evidence the FBI discovered of
efforts by Russia to try to influence
voters with Facebook and social media
but no evidence that I know of that they
actually changed the votes anywhere do
you think it's possible they could
somehow hack into the voting system and
change the outcome well the fact that we
have so many different voting systems is
actually protection against widespread
hacking across the country because again
you have separate systems that aren't
all United which makes it more clumsy
and cumbersome and problematic but does
stave off some kind of widespread attack
on the actual sort of hard systems that
being said the way that the Russians
interfered in 2016 was through
misinformation by planting lies in our
phones essentially misinformation about
candidates misinformation about what's
happening in elections to dissuade
people from coming home from actually
leaving their homes and going to the
polls misinformation about the issues
and the facts basically duping us into
believing false information so we cast
our ballots the way Vladimir Putin wants
us to and not the way that we should as
Americans free of free and fair elected
officials should be obviously
determination should be made by
Americans not by Putin so as much as
there's not direct hacking in the
infection of American elections by
foreign officials and adverse foreign
policy powers is very very serious which
again is why people need to self educate
not only about their rights but about
the facts through reputable news
organizations and original sources of
information not some friendly face on
Facebook that could actually be there by
virtue of a Russian bot professor
Kimberly Bailey I want to thank you so
much your new book what you need to know
about voting and why just out today it's
an important book for everyone and
important subject for us all to keep an
eye on thanks again professor Whaley
thanks Brian coming up this week's
winners and losers in the media see if
you agree with the editors of media done
their verdict over brian Stelter of CNN
and his showdown with a trump campaign
lawyer you're watching the law on crime
trial network
and we close out our program tonight
with this week's winners and losers in
the media as chosen by the staff at
mediate and we're joined by Aidan
McLaughlin is the editor in chief of
mediate part of the Dan Abrams media
empire as is the law and crime Network
and they didn't seemed like a week in
which important anchors and reporters
were holding the truth to power they
were yeah that I mean that's that's a
good way to start it off because our
first winner is anchor Shannon brief who
the Fox News anchor who's on at 11:00
p.m. I don't know if we have video of
her interview with lieutenant governor
Dan happy to do hexxus
all right let's take a look at that
let's take a look at that are you
overstating it by saying people's lives
will be in danger because of activities
like what we're seeing in Seattle
you bet when you take out law
enforcement when you let the mob control
your life this is no different than Isis
taking over cities in the Middle East
this these are people with guns
threatening people who may or may not
agree with them and this kumbaya is
patting people and throwing them off
buildings they're not beheading people
are throwing them off buildings but they
have taken away their freedom so she did
quite a job there Aden taking on the
lieutenant governor yeah yeah so that's
that's an elected official basically
comparing the Seattle protest zone which
has been known as the Capitol Hill
autonomous zone comparing what's going
on there to what Isis is doing in the
Middle East which is a sort of a
ludicrous comparison especially when you
talk to reporters on the ground who say
that it's been overwhelmingly peaceful
in that area and then it's an area in
Seattle where protesters are
demonstrating peacefully so shannon
bream was a fox news anchor inviting on
this lieutenant governor to talk about
these protests is one thing if she were
to allow him to view that sort of
alarmist rhetoric unchecked that would
be a problem but she did a really
admirable job of actually challenging
him on it and if you know in the rest of
that video actually Dan Patrick concede
that there is a difference between
peaceful protesters the United States
and Isis that may
the reaction he expected when an
appearance on fox news I take it sure
and you know I could point to some other
hosts on Fox News particularly the
opinion host that precedes shannon bream
in the primetime hours it might not have
actually pushed back on those comments
from dan patrick because they're a
little bit more in line with some of the
more alarmist coverage that you have on
the network when it comes to the seattle
autonomous zone so it was really
refreshing and you know solid reporting
for shannon bream to push back on that
that's why we gave her the winner of the
day now you've got a loser of the day
who's the White House press secretary
let's take a look at what she had to say
where the president stands as he
believes that these bases are most
notably identified by the heroes within
it by the acts that they did and winning
two world wars and defeating an arc
defeating fascism across the globe
that's what these bases stand for not
the names on them so he doesn't want to
change the names he's vehemently opposed
to that and also as I noted yesterday
where do you draw the lines are we to
remove from history our George
Washington or we have to remove Thomas
Jefferson are we to remove FDR and so
she stepped right into the middle of
that controversy Aidan right so that
press secretary Haley mcenany who's
defending Trump's opposition to renaming
sort of the Confederate the base of US
bases that are named after Confederate
General now this is something where the
White House is really out of step with
where the general public is moving just
today you had senator Mitch McConnell
the top Republican in the Senate who
said he would be open to discussing
renaming those bases that have been
named after Confederate generals like
Fort Bragg now to have the White House
come out and say in opposition of Mitch
McConnell in opposition of President
Donald Trump's top generals who have
also said that they're opening open to a
discussion about renaming these sports
is is you know it's not particularly in
line with where the country is moving in
terms of this and you know here's the
thing kami mcenany's defense is that
these bases are now known for more noble
causes like the fights in world will
want to
world war two that's not a particularly
good argument against renaming them that
where they've been named after
Confederate General though we didn't
think the argument stood up to much
scrutiny and it out of lockstep with
even the Republican Party right many
saying where is the fort Eisenhower
where is a fort Patton given some modern
day heroes then you moved on with a
winner at CNN with brian Stelter and his
showdown interview with a lawyer for the
Trump campaign
let's take a look about that at that
before we talk about it and so Morse
whatever holds commission that you're a
journalist you're not putting out facts
you are putting out activism is this
best remembered anti media strategy all
the way to election day so let me finish
are you you're just gonna interrupt me
this whole time or can we actually have
a reasonable dialogue this is why
everyone calls you fake names because
you finally bring me on to actually talk
about things and then yet you just
interrupt me and won't let me make my
point so my boss and it is important to
interrupt when you when you share adults
Aidan you called brian Stelter a winner
a Sunday see him as being too pushy and
aggressive let her talk sure so I think
it's important to know the background of
this interview before we go on to
discuss brian Stelter jenna ellis who is
a legal adviser to the Trump campaign
with appearing to discuss a cease and
desist letter that the campaign sent CNN
over a poll is the outlet published that
showed President Donald Trump getting
beaten in a national matchup to Joe
Biden by 14 points now that poll is 14
points is a lot but it's still pretty
much in line with a lot of the other
polling coming out in a head head
matchup between Trump and Biden so the
campaign sends a pretty absurd cease and
desist letter to the outlet over that
poll and Jenna Ellis comes on to discuss
it now she spent most of the interview
basically insulting CNN calling it fake
news insulting its ratings and we
thought it was admirable for brian
Stelter to have her on the show to
discuss this season to this letter and
that it wasn't his fault that the
interview devolved basically into a
shouting match where she was lobbing
insults at now i'd also like to add that
after the interview the Trump campaign
released a statement where they accused
Brian
filter of being sexist and demeaning
with his interview now if you watch the
interview it got really fiery and
explosive but Brian filter was really
just sort of trying to correct John
Ellis on Miss statements that she was
making about media and about polling so
I I don't take that truck a statement
from the Trump campaign to be anything
but in bad faith so that's really why we
made eyes the winner on that and I think
you're right it's important for Stelter
or anybody else in interview like that
to stop and correct the facts otherwise
that information gets out there and it's
never corrected exactly yeah and and he
did a pretty good job of that he got a
little bit I think mustard at one point
and and sort of lashed out at Jenna
Ellis but overall it was a worthwhile
conversation and I think it's it's
worthy for those kind of ideas to get
exposed that you know the Trump campaign
shouldn't just be sending cease and
desist letters the outlet they don't
like because they had polled that they
disagreed with right it was surprising
to see them come on his show and he did
the right thing because there are many
who would say let's not push it we want
to get the booking exactly yeah I can
imagine a lot of other hosts being a
little bit more pushed over by some of
the claims that Jenna Alice is making
but it was good that he was forceful
with good for him let's go on to the
next winner Jonathan hunt at Fox News
why Jonathan hunt at Fox News I just
want to make a vacation here the zone is
saddled that we talked about earlier in
this segment has been renamed to Capitol
Hill organized protested oh so now it's
gone from Chaz to being called a chop
that's a little bit of background on
what we're working with here now
Jonathan hunt is a correspondent at Fox
News and he is actually stationed in the
Chiapas own in Seattle and delivered a
pretty good report where he pushed back
on president Donald Trump's
characterization of this zone in Seattle
the president Donald Trump basically
described it like a war zone and sort of
threatened to send in the military to
crack down on this area of Seattle now
Jonathan hunt was there and actually
reported on Fox News that this area is
mostly peaceful and that there
really just an area of peaceful protest
at Seattle and that there's no cause for
alarm and you know this follows a trend
we had in recently in it I got a now say
we've got the clip of Jonathan let's
take a look at what he said precisely
hitting and the punching and the beating
and all the other things going on in
Seattle and you have a governor that
doesn't do a damn thing about it and you
have a mayor that doesn't know she's
alive
she's talking about it's gonna be a love
fest this summer know if they don't do
the job I'll do the job now the
president may have been watching the
same handful of videos over and over
again that have been posted repeatedly
on Twitter showing the handful of
violent incidents that have taken place
over the set last 72 hours but the truth
on the ground here Martha and having
spent much of the past 72 hours right
here inside the occupied protest zone is
that it remains and is at least for the
moment overwhelmingly peaceful exactly
as you described it and see a trend here
Fox anchors and reporters challenging
the White House the Trump line yeah for
sure and and and I think it's also
another trend that I think is really
important to follow is that it's another
example of reporters on the ground we're
actually in these places it's sort of
bringing whatever the reality is of the
protests whereas a lot of times you see
the national media and particularly
partisan media all the way up through
politicians like Dan Patrick which we
talked about earlier and President
Donald Trump pushing these also this
alarmist rhetoric about what's happening
on the ground and it's really really
valuable that you have news outlets that
are basically sending correspondents to
these areas to report the sort of what's
really happening and so it's really
important that especially on a network
like Fox News you have a correspondent
that they're saying no there's actually
not it's actually not chaos in this
region in Seattle it's overwhelmingly
peaceful here so I think it's an
important fact check against part of the
media and and partisan politics which
benefits from exacerbating these sort of
alarmist rhetoric and aidan to that
point do you
see a growing gap there between fox
opinion Sean Hannity Laura Ingraham and
the Fox reporters in the field this is a
particularly stark example of it just
because you had that segment from from
Jonathan hunt that report from the
ground and then in Fox News primetime he
said that at 7:00 p.m. on martha
maccallum show Fox News primetime starts
an hour later at 8:00 p.m. with Tucker
Carlton and they've gotten actually
gotten a lot of criticism Fox's
primetime host this week for overhyping
what's going on in these protests for
basically depicting you know places like
Minnesota Washington DC Seattle that
have seen pretty intense protests of
being these sort of war zones and a lot
of times they've been caught out using
old footage from last month to try and
make it seem like they're still ongoing
violent protests and looting in these
places whereas they've mostly calm down
and I think Jonathan hunt is it's
admirable that he did a good job of
actually saying what's happening on the
ground there in Seattle and my former
colleague Chris Wallace also talking
about the fact that he doesn't like a
lot of what he sees but he's there to as
we said earlier hold truth to power yeah
yeah Chris Wallace is often asked about
I think you're referencing a New York
Times profile of him that came out on
Sunday he's often asked about his
colleagues at Fox News very often Demers
in that interview he said you know I'm
not here to talk about what I do I do
not agree with on Fox News opinion I'm
here to report you know he does a
fantastic job of it okay Abe mcLaughlin
thank you so much and thank you all for
joining us today and thanks to our staff
will get us on the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]